are you are you still like uh like
hopping online and gaming a lot yeah
twitch.tv Slash songs where I just got
unbanned they had me banned on there I
was banned they banned everybody on
Twitch for a year though what'd you do I
can't I can't say what I did but you
know I'm back though you know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying they
just banned the kai sonat dude yeah he's
like the biggest guy on I'm like why
would you ban your biggest Creator and
he's like a nice dude he ain't doing
nothing crazy yeah so I mean I just feel
like you know they got their policies
and stuff like that it'd be and they'd
be [__] creators I heard huh the
split that they be paying their twitch
cream is [__] up yeah but you know
it's it's a platform and you know it is
it's good to be back on that but yeah
I'll be going crazy man y'all GTA GTA we
got RP got my own server so you have
your own server so you're like full uh
role play mode on there I'm saying lit
what happens if someone breaks character
on the mic
if it's too bad like if it's if they go
too far out of it you can get banned
from the server just kick them out I'm
saying so it's like we're about to go
rob somebody and they're like hey bro my
mom's tripping real quick hold on
shut the [__] up foreign
so they were [__] with you have you
uh dabbled in any mushrooms yet have you
done shrooms I got a funny mushroom
story bro hell yeah I took mushroom
before bro oh my God I ain't doing that
[__] I might do a little bit we'll do
some right now not right now all right
well I got him if you want one time I
locked myself in the in the closet in
Las Vegas was in a penthouse suite I'm
in the closet
lock myself in the cloud and I'm looking
up at the ceiling and it's like a
see-through ceiling and I'm looking
through the [__] just tweaking to the
morning to the sunrise
yeah that was the first trip second time
I did that [__] I was got down I just
passed out yeah it's one of the other
I woke up because it is hard if you're
in the studio like what the [__] I ain't
doing this [__] no more if you trip
super hard dude it's hard to go to sleep
because you start overthinking about
everything dissecting your whole life
I just laid in the bed and just wanted
to go to sleep I want that [__] to go
away did you did you find the
therapeutic were you like overthinking
[__] did you start crying
I just felt like I was in a [__] like
like that have you ever had sex on
mushrooms
yes how was that Lit yeah
it's not bad you know what I'm saying
hmm
what's the best drug to have sex on you
think
uh
uh probably like percocet or something
like that I've never done the Percocet
perk I'm scared of that especially with
the fetty out now what Percocet you
might get a percocet and end up [__]
out of here bro I can say no it's
serious though in the streets right now
kids don't do drugs it's bad yeah and
then they say uh I mean I've never done
ecstasy either I heard ecstasy is great
but I've just never done it uh you have
Molly I've only smoked weed in eight
shrooms
I think a little bit I think it's the
same thing MDMA right yeah that was
Trinidad James was that way he came to
my partner money I'm sweating everybody
popping mollies and [__]
Trinidad James did have the Molly wave
it's all good those are your soldier
wraps that's not a backwood
um how's your relationship these days
with Chief Keef That's my boy man I was
just with him the other day man that's
my boy man he came a long way to us
another person I'm proud of you feel me
seeing him come a long way to Come From
The Trenches Chiraq from nothing to you
family doing his thing I feel like like
you guys used to be together so much and
um for sure you know you were kind of
like
a child star before him so I'm sure he
learned a lot of the things like to do
and not to do from you you know because
he he was kind of like that generation
right after you yeah now for sure that's
my boy man like we just be kicking it
man you know what I'm saying like you
know we just be kicking it cool and then
you know just talking about [__] smoking
and just gonna be on [__]